oggi vi voglio parlare di una persona
around schwarz quando hanno gli hanno
dedicato un documentario l'anno scorso
nel 2014 l'anno intitolato the internet
o boy il pupillo di internet è molto
difficile mettere aaron in categorie
precise e stato un attivista un
programmatore un ricercatore
io aggiungerei sicuramente un hacker in
senso buono e un intellettuale uno
scrittore è più semplice però è fare una
lista per quanto tecnica di progetti a
cui lui ha collaborato sono decine e
decine aaron a 14 anni erano del gruppo
che scrisse rss
magari voi non dice molto ma era ubiquo
nella blogosfera fino a dieci anni fa e
costruì a 15 anni le creative commons
occupandosi della parte tecnica
oggi le creative commons sono circa in
un miliardo di contenuti sono delle
licenze libere che rendono il copyright
più flessibile e aperto sono per esempio
la licenza di wikipedia arona vent'anni
diventa un piccolo start up per
costruisce una cosa che fondò una cosa
chiamata reddit diventa milionario da un
giorno all'altro pro aaron sinceramente
non fregava tanto dei soldi o della fama
continua a fare quello che ha sempre
fatto costruire un internet libera
aperta e collaborativa collabora con
internet archive e open library due
biblioteche digitali che stanno
letteralmente salvando il web
preservando terabyte e terabyte di
internet che altrimenti andrebbe perduto
sono archivi di memoria digitale diventa
uno dei protagonisti della lotta contro
sopa una legge bavaglio e che qualche
anno fa costrinse persino wikipedia a
fare sciopero e andare in black out
perché avrebbe limitato enormemente la
libertà di espressione su internet
quello che in aaron assolutamente
colpisce è una straordinaria formidabile
e feroce curiosità aaron ce lo dice lui
stesso nel suo blog era capace di
leggere fino a 150 libri l'anno tutti i
saggi dall'economia la teoria politica
alla storia dell'educazione
all'informatica
girava con il capitale di marx
sottobraccio a 16 anni
aaron e questo ce lo racconta il suo
fratello in un momento molto toccante
del documentario che dovete
assolutamente vedere e aveva imparato ad
imparare prestissimo ci racconta sua
madre che a un certo punto lei stava
cucinando e un aaron aveva due anni e
mezzo era seduto nel seggiolone elesse
l'avviso sul frigo che lei aveva appena
attaccato con le calamite aaron però
scopre una cosa importante questa sete
di conoscenza a uno specchio a un suo
doppio cioè fame di conoscenza diventa
fame di condividere conoscenza perché la
conoscenza deve essere condivisa
se guardiamo ai progetti di aaron
vediamo che sono tutti strumenti
tecnologie per l'accesso
all'informazione in internet archive
preserva la memorial rss permetteva ai
blog di sincronizzarsi le creative
commons sono un copyright e quindi
rendono accessibile alle persone del
contenuto il contenuto creativo
l'accesso all'informazione nasce da un
concetto estremamente semplice ma
fondamentale per quanto banale cioè che
l'informazione è potere formazione
potere che noi basta pensarci un secondo
troviamo ovunque troviamo nelle scuole
nelle biblioteche nell'università
l'informazione è potere lo diceva don
milani diceva anche la montessori cioè
dare accesso all'informazione delle
persone vuol dire fa compiere un atto
democratico la nostra democrazia
letteralmente si basa sul dare accesso
l'apprendimento all'educazione
senza questo non c'è democrazia è un
atto di empowerment di abilitazione
dell'altro il fatto che aaron arriva a
questo da genio quale arriva questo dal
suo retroterra culturale che è quello
della hacker
lacker come costruttore non come
distruttore quando conosci il codice e
ai le competenze per leggerlo poi
modificarlo poi renderlo tuo puoi fargli
fare quello che vuoi
quindi spiegare il mondo diventa una
condizione necessaria per piegare il
mondo per renderlo malleabile per
poterlo modificare rendere il mondo un
posto migliore presuppone un accesso a
questa informazione e quindi se tutte le
istituzioni sono sociali sono fatte da
persone quindi fondamentalmente sono
cultura quindi fondamentalmente sono
fatta di parole tutto diventa a car
abile nel momento in cui conosci il
codice e sai come si modifica
ma questa cosa non la fai da solo se
rendo il mondo open source ad accesso
aperto tutti potranno aggiustarlo
rendere il mondo un posto migliore non
diventa una un atto singolo di eroismo
ma diventa un atto di costruzione
collettiva nel circa nel 2011
aaron si interessa a questa cosa che si
chiama open access grande movimento per
l'accesso libero alla letteratura
scientifica il mondo della letteratura
scientifica magari c'è qualche
universitario in sala è un mondo
assolutamente caotico e controverso
contraddittorio pochissimi grandi
editori hanno le chiavi del potere
rendendo scarso ciò che scarso non è
cioè l'informazione scientifica e aaron
si appassiona al tema scrive questa cosa
che si chiama open access
brilla open access manifesto lo scrive
tra l'altro qui in italia le prime frasi
era l'informazione potere aaron scarica
decine di migliaia di articoli centinaia
di migliaia di articoli da un database
accademico j store viene beccato life di
hi lo aveva attenzionato non un hacker
di tale genio non sicuramente non passa
inosservato capisce che la sua
opportunità per fare di aaron
una un esempio vogliono dargli una
condanna esemplare per mostrare a tutti
gli hacker là fuori che il mondo non si
cambia con un paio di righe di codice
gli viene aaron viene fatto oggetto di
una vera e propria persecuzione
giudiziaria per aver scaricato centinaia
di migliaia di articoli da un database
accademico e poteva farlo però non in
tale scala e gli vengono contestati atti
di pirateria informatica
rischia fino a 35 anni spende milioni di
dollari in questa causa legale e viene
equiparato né più né meno che a un
terrorista
due anni dopo il suo primo arresto aaron
si impicca in casa sua a new york aveva
26 anni
il punto è che il potere lo sa che
l'informazione potere e se decidi di
essere l'ingranaggio che ferma il
sistema beh questi ti schiaccerà con
tutta la forza combinata degli
ingranaggi attorno a te è una cosa che
abbiamo già visto recentemente con
edwards no del chelsea manning julian
assange tutti i casi diversi eppure
simili gente come leva a dare accesso
all'informazione per quanto controversa
vorrei farvi vedere adesso un minuto
dall'ultima intervista di arros fars
pochi mesi prima di morire ma anche nei
sottotitoli adesso arrivano
aaron dice qui una cosa banale quanto
fondamentale ci sono due prospettive
polarizzate di internet internet è
orribile è una piattaforma di spionaggio
di massa viene utilizzato per spiare per
controllare per opprimere invece
un'altra prospettiva internet fantastico
libera un posto di totale libertà di
espressione
in realtà queste cose sono uguali sono
vere entrambi sono sono cose che il
coesistono allo stesso modo internet
troppo complesso per essere una cosa
sola e aaron dice le cose importanti il
software dipende da noi quello che
vincerà perché internet sarà sempre
questa cosa complicata
io volevo finire non con parole mie
perché non ne ho ma con parole di
qualcuno più bravo e farò di viventi non
è qualcosa che sarà se ce n'è uno e
quello che è già qui l'inferno che
abitiamo tutti i giorni che formiamo
stando insieme due modi ci sono per non
soffrirne
il primo riesce facile a molti accettare
l'inferno e diventarne parte fino al
punto di non vederlo più
secondo è rischioso ed esige attenzione
e apprendimento continui cercare e saper
riconoscere chi e cosa in mezzo
all'inferno non è inferno e farlo durare
e dargli spazio
grazie